attention deficit hyperactivity disorder
or ADHD is mostly of genetic origin
symptoms are categorized as inattentive
or hyperactive but people can experience
both in all sorts of forms which means
there is a spectrum of
presentations Lisa a young girl who
wants to become a writer will help us
understand what it means to grow up with
ADH h d her Story shows how her atypical
brain makes it harder to achieve her
dreams during early childhood Lisa has a
tough time paying attention she gets
distracted starts daydreaming and
frequently forgets or loses things
because her senses pick up too much
information for her brain to process she
gets overwhelmed and as a result she
often cries or becomes frustrated her
parents who don't know better scold her
instead of helping her to deal with the
pain in Primary School Lisa can't sit
still and often disrupts the class she
is smart but besides English and the
Arts has bad grades it is not long
before Lisa is branded as lazy as
someone who doesn't use her
potential it's also hard for Lisa to
make friends she feels different and is
bullied
the few friends she has tell her that
she is too emotional but admire
her in Middle School Lisa starts
doodling to help her stay focused but
her teacher doesn't like that and scolds
her because he thinks she is distracted
and so she masks her in attention and
puts all her energy into nodding and
making eye
contact but by doing so she loses her
concentration entirely and ends up not
listening at all this is where she turns
inwards and develops a passion for
creative
writing during High School her mind
starts racing with a thousand thoughts
in her head she now wears headphones to
isolate the noise and calm herself down
but when she has her period even that
doesn't help anymore and she goes
through intense mood swings she begins
binge eating and starts
smoking at 8 19 Lisa gets into a top
literature program but the
responsibilities of everyday life are
overwhelming she feels burned out stops
showering cleaning up and going to
class one evening she tells her best
friend that she can't handle it anymore
all her life she has been too different
to ever fit in all her life she felt
like a burden to others her friend tells
her about a psychiatrist and as a last
Resort Lisa goes to see her the
psychiatrist first thinks it's
depression but then asking about Lisa's
childhood and family history she notices
something else and requests more tests a
few weeks later Lisa is diagnosed with
ADHD and
depression the doctor explains to Lisa
that ADHD is not limited to the most
well-known symptoms for example people
with ADHD also have deficit in their
executive functions such as working
memory time perception or emotional
regulation some also get sleepy when
drinking
coffee however they often also have
higher levels of creativity and more
caring and are more Curious than their
peers making them great artists or
scientists plus they react more calmly
to stressful situations some become
Fearless firefighters or outstanding Sur
the psychiatrist goes on to explain that
ADHD symptoms can be treated with
medication and therapy and that regular
sleep and exercise can help
too when Lisa takes her first pill the
next day she bursts into tears for the
first time in her life her mind is quiet
it does not take an effort for her to
get up and shower she realizes that
throughout her whole life she has spent
so much energy trying to do things that
others do without even
thinking although medication helps Lisa
knows that it is not enough she has to
make changes to her life and find work
that plays to her strengths by the time
she is 30 she learns to accept and
appreciate her neurod Divergence and her
atypical mind is celebrated after the
publication of her first
novel what do you think if you had or
have ADHD would you adapt your brain to
your life by taking pills going to
therapy or masking your behaviors or is
the solution to accept your differences
and adopt a lifestyle that fits who you
are tell us in the comments
[Music]
below
if you found this helpful check out our
other videos and subscribe if you want
to support our work join us on